بين هنا في الاستوديو السيده روزي داياز
المتحدثه الرسميه باسم الحكومه البريطانيه
في الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا سيده روزي
ما الذي قدمته الحكومه البريطانيه حتى
الان في اطار جهود الاغاثه لاسيما في شمال
غرب سوريا نعم وشكرا لاستضافه بشكل عام
بريطانيا هي ثاني اكبر مانع الى سوريا منذ
بدايه الحرب ولهذه هي الكارثه بريطانيا
سمحت سحبت
8 مليون جنيه استرليني للمنطقه المتضررين
وخاصه في منطقه شمال غرب سوريا
الان نوفر ثلاث فاصل ثمانيه مليون جنيه
الى
البايضه لدعم عمليات البحث والانقاذ وايضا
المعادلات الطبيه
وسنستمر مع هذه المساعده والان ايضا
نرسلبيه
وندى المشاري لاعاده فتره المدارس والطرق
وكمان اعاده ربط الخدمات وكل هذه
المساعدات بريطانيا هي جاهزه لتوفير
المتضررين في المنطقه وايضا خاصه في شمال
الغرب سوريا طب ما هي ابرز العقبات التي
تواجه بريطانيا وايضا المجتمع الدولي خاصه
في ظل انتقادات وجهات للمجتمع الدولي بانه
لم يستجب بسرعه الكافيه
لانقاذ الشعب السوري وهذه الانتقادات جاءت
ايضا من وكيل الامم المتحده للشؤون
الانسانيه نعم كم قالت اللمامه المتحده
حول فشل العالم من حيث المتضررين في سوريا
مع هذا الراعي ولكن السؤال المهم هو لماذا
لا نستطيع ان نوفر او نسلم
المساعده الى سوريا لان وصلت المساعده الى
المتضررين في تركيا
والجواب هو واضح جدا بسبب المشاكل على
الهدوء وعدم عدم دخول المساعدات لان كان
هناك
نقطه البور واحده فقط لكل المصائب من من
الاعلى
فقط اليوم النظام الاسد
يوافق ان يفطى النقاط الابور الاخرى ولكن
هذا متاخر جدا جدا من حيث من حيث الشعب
السوري
يعني بمفهوم لندن ما هو المسار الانسب
لايصال هذه المساعدات بشكل عاجل وكما
تفضلت الان كذا معبر باب الهوى مفتوحا
والان النظام السوري بحسب مرتين يوافق على
ايضا دخول المساعدات من معبرين
بمفهوم بريطانيا ما هو المسار الانسب
لتسريع ايصال المساعده نعم اولا بريطانيا
منذ وقت طويل الدفعات
لتمديد التفويض
لدخول
المساعدات عبر الهدود ام في مجلس الامن
وفي يناير كان هناك تجديد المفويض لسته
شهور لكن هذا ليس كافي
الفتره القصيره
تؤدي الى عدم الاستقرار حول تسليم
المصادقه
ولهذا الان ندفى
اعضاء مجلس
لتجديد التفويض لاثناث 12 شهر على اقل
وهذا يجب على كل اعضاء مجلس الامن بما في
ذلك روسيا ان يتعاون لتحقيق هذا هذا الحل
من اجل الشعب السوري هل لديكم اي امل في
اي تحقق كذلك خاصه ان كل تجديد ندخل في
مرحله من الجدل والاخذ والرد قبل ان يتم
اليوم هنالك حديث عن ازمات موازيه وخشيه
من ازمات موازيه بعد الزلزال كيف يمكن ان
تقدم بريطانيا المساعده في هذا الاطار نعم
الان
فهذا قبل الزلزال اربعه مليون سوري في
شمال الغرب سوريا اعتمدوا على المساعده
الدوليه من خلال الباب الحاره
وكان هناك
مستوى معاناه الشعب السوري
كبير جدا قبل هذا قبل هذا هذا الزلزال
الشيء الحزين جدا ان هناك تركيز الاسيا
لكن هذا هذه الكارثه هي عن حول الشعب
السوري ومعاناه شعب ليس حول سياسه وكل
الاطراف خارج وداخل سوريا لكن يجب عليهم
ان يعملوا مع بعض لحل ليس فقط هذه الكارثه
وايضا الوضع في سوريا بشكل عام وخاصه يجب
على النظام الاسد
لينخرط مع العمليه السياسيه
لتعقيق السلام الذي يستحق شعب السوري نعم
كما تفضلت هذه الازمه كشفت هشاشه هذه
المنطقه رغم الدعم الكبير وك تفضلتي
بريطانيا كانت من اكبر الداعمين لهذه
المنطقه لشمال غرب سوريا ايضا ما هي
استراتيجيه لندن لوضع حد
لهذه الماساه الممتده منذ عام 2011 في
مناطق شمال غرب سوريا سياسيا نتحدث طبعا
قلت نستمر ان نؤمن في العمليه السياسيه
لكن هذا هذه هي العمليه تعتمر على تعاون
من كل الاعتراف بما في ذلك النظام الاسد
وايضا الشركاء شركائه مثل روسيا والاطراف
الاخرى لان من المستهيل
للمجتمع الدولي
يفرض حال على سوريا بدون مشاركه النظام
وسنستمر ان
نحس النظام ليشارك في العمليه اذا ربطنا
هذه الكارثه بما تفضلت به
البيضات الائتلاف المعارض ينتقدون ان يكون
للاسد كلمه في مناطق لا يسيطر عليها وان
الامم المتحده انتظرت الى ان يوافق الرئيس
الاسد على فتح معابر جديده كيف تنظرون الى
هذه الانتقادات نعم من الواضح ان
كل الشعب السوري الان
عندهم حاجات فوريه وكبيره ويجب ان النظام
وكل الاعتراف ان يركز ليس فقط على مناطق
معينه على كل المناطق المتدمره في سوريا
وفي هذا الخصوص بريطانيا
ستستمر ان تضيف النظام والاطراف الاخرى
سنتعاون معلومه من المتحده وشركائنا
لتحقيق هذا
شكرا روزي دي اعز المتحدثه الرسميه باسم
الحكومه البريطانيه في الشرق الاوسط وشمال
افريقيا